[Music]
do you know a peter parker who's
spider-man yes is that him no
can you please explain what is going on
after i shut that spell down we started
getting visitors from every universe
multiverse is real
i need you to capture them before they
destroy the fabric of reality i'm gonna
need some help
you guys ready let's catch some
multiverse men
spider-man your way home what was your
name again dr otto octavius seriously
what's your actual name
[Music]
ever since i got bit by that spider
i've only had one week
where my life has felt normal that was
when you found out
[Music]
when you botched that spell where you
wanted everyone to forget the peter
parker spiderman
we started getting some visitors
[Applause]
from every
universe
hello peter
you're not peter parker
i'm sorry what was your name again dr
otto octavius
[Laughter]
wait no seriously what's your actual
name
there are others out there we need to
send them back
so scooby doo this crap you know all
this is kind of your mess i know a
couple of magic words myself starting
with the word please
please
scooby-doo this crap
you're flying out into the darkness
to fight ghosts what do you mean
they all die fighting spider-man
it's their fate
i'm sorry kid
yeah me too
don't
but there has to be another way there
isn't
they're a danger to our
universe you know to take this away from
me
peter
you're struggling
and everything you want
while the world tries to make you choose
this is all my fault i can't save
everyone
[Applause]
what's happening they're starting to
come through
and i can't stop them
december 17th exclusively in movie
theaters tickets on sale november 29th
spider monday
[Music]
you